- Okay, well speaking of competitive,
is it true that you are in a-
This is just interesting to
me 'cause I'm a wordsmith.
I love words.
You're in a Wordle group
with Chris's "Silver Linings"
co-star Bradley Cooper.
Is this true?
- No, I'm trying to get into it.
I'm being velvet-roped
by the bouncer here.
He's tellin' me that I
gotta get a cooler plus one
or something.
- [Kelly] It's not easy.
- Well, we play-
So there's Octordle
which is the eight words.
And then Quordle which is the four words.
And then Wordle, which is the one.
So we play all three and
you add up your score.
- All right, Will Hunting-
(Kelly & Matt laugh)
- No, I mean we-
It's very, very competitive.
Will Arnet is in it.
Bradley Cooper, Jason Bateman-
- And I'm not.
Which is fine.
I don't resent-
- No, I advised you-
You're welcome to join.
I just advised you-
We call it the Nerdle League.
I was like, you can join the Nerdle League
but you might want to
get your scores down.
- The truth is, they told
me what their scores were.
I was like, I can get in.
Then I did it a couple times.
I was like, I might need to train.
- That's hard for me.
Like, I love words, but it's hard.
Like, especially the five.
I'm always like, what?
And I have friends that
are brilliant at it.
I wouldn't be invited either.
I do love that y'all play that though.
So what's the last Wordle word
that was controversial for you guys?
What's the last one you were like, "No."
- Well, I'm not a fan of
Quordle, which is the four words.
The people are a little sinister.
Because they'll do words like rarer.
And I'm like, you're really
gonna do three Rs in one word?
Like, you guys suck.
You know what I mean?
Because it's whenever you flame out,
like when you don't get enough-
And you know, you blow out.
We call it a blow out.
And I'm just like, oh, I blew out on-
And it's always Quordle that gets me.
And I'm always angry
when I look at the word
and I'm like, you know?
And it's like, you know,
pappy or something.
- I was doing that with
my mom the other day.
And she really objected to sooth.
Sooth was a word.
I said, no, it's truth,
it's like for soth.
And she said, well that's archaic.
That's not fair.
- Yeah, this is my
mother playing Scrabble.
She will yell at me and my sister.
And she'll be like "qi," really?
Q-I, we're gonna-
Okay, we're going with it.
Okay, cool.
- If you play Scrabble,
you're all about the the qi.
- Yeah, like come on.
- Q 18.
- If you don't have a U, you are true.
- Or za, that's the worst.
For pizza, za.
- Nah, I don't buy that.
- My sister-
- It's not in the Scrabble dictionary.
- She used za when we were
in New York, first Christmas.
And my mom lost her (bleep).
She was like, that's not a word.
And she's a teacher so it
was very hard to swallow.
- Whether or not a thing is
a word dispute has caused
some serious fractions.
- Because then you look it up
and kind of, everything's a word.
- Everything's a word.
You go to the Scrabble dictionary
on your phone.
- You can't just use the urban
dictionary 'cause everything's
slang for something.
Like how, how does this mean 50-?
- Oh, my mom will get so upset about it.
It's so funny.
Za? Okay, we're going with za.
- I mean then, okay, well,
does anything, any expression-
We'll get into some arguments now.
- I love the way this interview went.
I know my mom and sister
are gonna be like, what?
You got these people here
and you talk about what?